it has been a busy first month on the
job for New York City's new police
commissioner Dermot Shay was sworn in in
December on December 2nd after rising
through the ranks over 28 years
Shane joined the NYPD in 1991 as a
patrol officer in the Bronx that city
the city that year had more than 2000
murders in 2018 the number fell below
300 commissioner Shea joins us this
morning welcome to the table thank you
thank you for having me good morning
everyone
let's start with the hate crimes the
governor of New York said given the
incident that happened at the rabbi's
house over the weekend it was the 13th
anti-semitic attack in New York over the
last three weeks I posted on Twitter
that you were coming on this morning and
I asked people what do you want us to
ask the commissioner and Jorge in
Florida said is he going to put more
people on the street to deal with hate
crimes yeah well that's a great question
and and the answer is emphatic yes that
actually started a couple weeks ago here
in New York City when you just three
weeks ago with the Jersey City attack
and that horrific incident we stepped up
patrols specifically in Jewish
neighborhoods specifically around houses
of worship and that has continued and
now intensified with this latest
terrible terrible attack in Muncie this
weekend so you can expect to see
increased uniform patrols as well as
plainclothes control patrols we have
units from our critical response our
strategic response group as well as
precinct officers patrolling these areas
houses of worship will see increased
patrols and they it's all with the
backdrop really to keep people safe but
also to make people feel safe when you
talk about increasing patrols can you
tell us how many you were directing just
in that area yeah well I will get
without getting into specifics of
deployment there will be many officers
deployed on each tour when you're
specifically looking at areas such as
the nine o the nine floor that's
Williamsburg okay you're looking at
Borough Park when you're looking at
Crown Heights we will keep the Jewish
community safe and we have a zero
tolerance when it comes to hate crimes
in New York City people's nerves are
rattled as you can imagine and now when
we're expecting a million people to come
in to Times Square
what are you monitoring in terms of
threats and what are the plans to keep
people safe there yeah so first first
I'd like to reach
or people there are no credible threats
specifically about this incident
tomorrow and and take a look at the
weather the weather is cooperating for a
change last year we were out there in
rain parkas and bone-chilling cold it's
gonna be a nice night we want all New
Yorkers to come out enjoy it remember
the rules
get there early use mass transportation
no alcohol so leave the backpacks at
home leave the chairs at home come out
have a great time and you will be very
safe in Times Square good to know you
know another story that has made
national headlines that happened here in
New York City is the death of Tesla
majors a Bernard college student and
there was a 14 year old that was
questioned and released what's the very
latest with that investigation has
anyone been charged there was an initial
arrest within a day or two of the 13
year old that 13 year old based on the
age is being prosecuted in family court
I think that was widely reported correct
we have contacted through attorneys two
other individuals those about 14 years
of age we are working since the night of
the incident I'll tell you Sarika
hand-in-hand with the Manhattan DA's
office as well as the coop counsel for
New York City based on the ages of the
individuals the detectives working are
taking their work very seriously working
methodically and the investigation
continues some people have said this
sort of reminds them of the Central Park
five in 1989 what sort of things has the
police department learned from that
because we know those five that were
charged and convicted were exonerated
but how has that informed the police
department today as we enter 2020 and
how you'll handle this situation yeah if
you look let me do the math quick in my
head 30 probably 34 years and a lot has
changed when you look at policies how we
investigate crimes I can tell you that
the detectives were conducting for
example in the case of the first
individual interrogations where we
conduct interrogations now all on
videotape all in the precinct station
houses that's conducted with member of
the family present in
in the old case they we were not at the
same exact level in terms of having our
own video equipment in without getting
into the old case but you know there is
a process in court and this will all be
reviewed ultimately and that's why
ultimately we want to make sure that the
the arrest that we make stands up in
court and we get justice for the victim
and her family and really quickly if we
could ask you we know that the Special
Victims Division is currently facing an
internal affairs probe it does not have
to do with the handling of the Harvey
Weinstein case but we know that trial is
expected to start January 6 it's Monday
coming up how do you think that could
impact that case the Harvey Weinstein
case the Harvey Weinstein case ongoing
case as you know I can tell you that
when I came in to the as the Chief of
Detectives I'm losing track of time but
probably around April of 2018
conducted a review of the Special
Victims Division at that time shortly
thereafter I put a new chief in charge
of it chief Judi Harris and I think
she's done a phenomenal job leading the
men and women of the Special Victims
Division I had the pleasure of being the
Chief of Detectives and I saw a lot of
great work being done throughout that
Bureau one of the things that stands out
is that Division you have a work that
they do for the victims in those cases
sometimes young children sexually abused
women sexually abused I have the utmost
confidence in the Special Victims
Division alright Commissioner Dermot
Shay thank you so much for joining us
you